hey guys I'm Ilana welcome to my channel
today I'm playing until dawn with the
help of my mum hi Susan
I figured I would need the help because
it's a stereo game and I'm a total wuss
when I come home yes we go home I hand
you want to get really scary yes so
right now we're looking at a butterfly
smallest decision can dramatically
change the future
so the idea what that is supposed to be
that this is a really choice based game
the plot that I played before which I
played at a convention I think in Boston
had a pod where I had to choose between
killing myself from killing someone else
so I think the idea is that whatever you
choose chooses who dies and who lives
and I guess this supposed to be a lot of
different options your story is one of
many possibilities exactly I want to do
so many possibilities there actually
well that could be a lie there could be
overstating it choose your actions
carefully okay creepy cottage in the
woods good place to start
and of course it's cold in nighttime
call them nighttime foggy means standard
stuff
okay so that wasn't good no there is
nobody panic so it actually looks quite
pretty
now it's really really creepy he's got
good eye some random okay cool
I'm just looking out for my girl
so I think the idea is that this is like
a bunch of teenagers who are on vacation
yeah for a weekend or something and they
are playing someone at this point yeah
that's Hayden yeah I think yeah I can
tell the first time I played it looked
like I could see what she was annoying -
annoying it's Hannah
hey so they're all in there that girl's
been went to there
she's busy with counsel we know I guess
I need you to be doing much I've seen
someone just be us this weekend hit
things on his back dad said it just be
else this weekend so it's a dad so you
just mentioned basically mention in the
woods it's two people tossed out here
and there's been a party
I'm guessing it's because of a party
mm-hmm
the way you have to flip that kind of
annoying it's a special fruit mixes
panna you look so damn hot mouth shut
but I bet you're even better out of it
come to the guest room at 2:00 a.m. Mike
so that's what's happening right now
that's Hannah's just going up there what
a naive sister get herself into now
Mike's the mommy yes right and this is
Hannah's just I think this is Hannah
sister this is their house it's very
nice I came here for a weekend well I
think it's a dad's like vacation Cody
change yeah I'm taking yeah yeah okay no
I don't went through the door on the
other side yeah but I mean I guess I
probably should go look for Hannah
should might try and stop or divine a
minor he's obviously a little look
around yeah but I don't have any benefit
from that I've already seen them
well she got the note yeah well that's
why she's here maybe we should start
with a little you know making out and
see where it goes from there you know
you can't stop me I'm doing it you know
I was thinking maybe she should just
dumb coupling fist yeah Hannibal yeah
that'll do what are you doing yeah
that's really mean that's awful chirps
here's a camera that's terrible yeah
so that was Hannah - what possible oh is
it yeah okay we're at the ocean gonna
find the others justice I'm gonna come
out what am I gonna get for my gosh
nothing where's my sister
it was pretty mean what did you do she
still doesn't know anything
another night she'd be able to figure
out I go after her right now Mike
okay push the correct action button
towards Andrews s up what did that mean
action it's a QTE
we're just which way Boston's safe I
think site
it's a QuickTime event basically you
have to press the buttons quickly as you
can before it runs out or you'll fail I
imaginated just because I like tripping
on something right they're generally
hated because it like adds difficulty
out of you pressing a button in time
rather than being an actual gameplay
mechanic soda tastes so good I damn it
yeah games like this always have that I
think she's just running around rocks
I'm not anything I'm not looking while
she's running excuse me actually quite
making that run Jesus [ __ ] [ __ ] Birds
it's way too many adjectives like Jesus
function I don't think that Jesus would
do that you know I don't think Jesus is
that kind of guy this is probably take
selfie I mean another voice is that no
I'll take a selfie so I can't see any
footprints can you know yeah so I can
Valentini going the wrong way so can we
go back well how are we going to find
her if we can't secrets for prints
I'm assuming so she should have gone for
the noise do you think oh it's linear so
you know this part is obvious there's no
you know if I try and walk through here
it's just going to stop me at some point
like I'm not that I can't
it's only gonna take us there you go one
way yeah where did that go to the rock
it just disappeared into the ground hold
the wand or foster I did not just press
l1 that was
it hit us totally some kind of total
I think that was done oh I think that
was Hannah dying
that's my footprint Stan I was up free
here about that she didn't see I don't
think that she would have seen it it
would be like a collectible bit well
that's all I got there that's it did you
see the car yeah it must have been a
dragon too right this looks like sex
dragon won't be fired
it's definitely dragons that's the most
realistic option look what is that
co-op can you go up there and set up a
deist you don't think so no you don't
want to hell would that be it won't look
me up there well it's just too weird
okay it was a drag another person to you
by now that's how
why don't you just like go into a room
and cry ooh good thing stools the dragon
feet it's definitely the dragon
sounds like a bargain no you see dragon
it's just a really tiny dragon yeah
someone's abandoned what a journalist
food and I'm also how are you gonna
explain about it now
Sophie's trip ruined the mostess railway
the selfie stick and we did have one did
they go forward they do
Levin
dragon dragon arrived
oh she was gonna die either way right oh
they both side way yay
right right excellent all right lift it
off to a great start
all right little bit man dropping henna
well I think there's a little bit you
know I figured it was either gonna be
them both die or potentially save one of
them unless we could have had a hang it
kind of like swing a hand up to grab the
guy's hand you see no one could change
what happened last year
the past is beyond our control is in
order to move forward there's freedom
everything you do ever do music animates
no I'm will open doors to the future I
want you to remember this I want you to
remember this as you play your game
every single choice will affect your
fate and the fate of those around you
good yeah facial animation sees
expressions are very impressive I'm just
like he's all you see those two commands
with this game he's bouncing really good
and I want to help you see it through
his cheeks sometime hmm sometimes these
things can be a little scary even
terrifying but I'm here to make sure
that no matter how upsetting things may
get you will always find a way to work
through it okay
all right we will start with a simple
exercise
could you please always company cart and
I want you to look at the meter on the
other side I think I have something we
wants but I don't know why the central
stands or honestly in order to get the
most out this is disturb or what
happened what happened when I've been
the two girls - I don't know if it's
related to that might not be good
there's someone there yeah but I think
that's definitely be outgoing
oh because why would so how did that
picture make you feel remember be honest
it's creepy yeah makes me feel uneasy
yeah okay
all this day's good what do you think
that makes you feel uneasy scarecrow
yes yes this decorate this cake way I
think the shadows are a bit we had to
but I mean I don't on still not good oh
let's see Jerry crow we're not there
would you feel comfortable staying there
on your own for a period of time it's
not there whatever it's a little staying
about myself
yeah yeah why I don't like the barn
either I think my whole scenes scary but
you stayed yeah I'm gonna say yes yeah
why why I just I don't know if that lot
dance
don't fear of bones yeah all right
and what if I told you that this cottage
was haunted that's a cottage if this
cottage was wanted I'd be scared yeah Oh
College Oregon hmm all right all right
ourselves that you suffer from
significant figure out of the
supernatural
like the junction at it's very picture
of not paying to this is it dust flying
background we remember did you saw me
game this is only a game so it's gonna
be well we seem to be out of time for
this cities but I wonder if the
reference to games like dogwood sluggers
it's all set up
okay like maybe I am the killer and I
make the decisions or you know it's been
like some kind of sick TV show with
everything happens in the future is a
game okay just with real people like
soul kind of thing
could be